hey ben so i want to ask you a question
you said earlier that a lot of democrats
are uncomfortable
looking at pictures of children that are
being aborted
yet i would say that you and many other
republicans would feel equally
uncomfortable
looking at pictures of sandy hook
victims who were shot how can you
honestly stand up here and say
that you support abortion you support
government intervention excuse me
you support government intervention to
make abortion illegal which is designed
to kill someone and yet you can stand up
here and say you don't want government
intervention
for guns which are also designed to kill
people because guns are not designed to
kill children guns are designed to kill
bad guys if
operated by a proper person there's not
an abortion in the world that doesn't
end with the death of a baby
so so
honestly the reason so i have
i have so i i have no problem with
looking at the pictures of gun violence
victims other than the problems any
other human being left or right would
have with looking at those pictures
which is that they're horrific and
deeply disturbing and very upsetting
but i don't feel any sense of guilt or
avoidance
like i can't look at this picture
because i bear some sort of
responsibility for this it is impossible
not to look at a picture of an aborted
baby and say this was disconnected
from the act that i approve because the
act is the killing of the baby
there's no there's no policy that i
approve of that ends with the murder of
children
okay there is a policy that is designed
for the murder of children which is what
abortion is
yeah that's fine you have a quick
follow-up this month sir okay so but if
all people
right you said that um once the cells
come together you said those are
considered people which i can understand
i can because i said that's considered a
human life human life right yes
why is this human life being killed in
another human life being killed by gun
violence
why is that any different again it's not
a matter of
the value of the human life being
different it's it's equally as evil
and and tragic and horrific and
disgusting
when people kill fully formed children
who are outside the womb
my point is that the act that connects
to the killing of the children
is not connected to my position on guns
the act that connects to the killing of
unborn babies is connected to the
legalization of abortion
the reason that i want people to be able
to exercise their second amendment
rights is to shoot
pieces like the people who go into like
the people who go into schools
and and shoot up children both my i have
two kids they both go to a jewish school
which means they are on the target list
for somebody out there
right jewish schools jewish schools are
disproportionately targeted
unfortunately
in the united states i went to a jewish
school when i was in high school
there were bomb threats legitimately
every couple of months
in 1999 there was a white supremacist
who drove by our jewish day school saw
an armed guard outside
proceeded to drive away went to the west
valley jcc and shot up the west valley
jcc
the reason that i'm in favor of gun
rights is because i want that armed
guard outside
carrying the gun to dissuade people from
going inside the school and shooting the
kid
i'm not in favor of